[Music]
nothing steals my valuable attention
away from the meaningful things in life
quite like a fake threat of kidnapped
children about to be killed by a
fabricated serial killer
why is he photographing each movement
instead of the much more efficient
option of videoing and taking
screenshots the Saint 1989 man it's 2008
and that technology is readily available
ah sudden Colonel Sanders for that the
academics are wide open
I am positive Joe was instructed to sit
directly in front of the projector like
this because it looked cool and it does
not it looks painful what did you study
criminal justice but sports appreciation
was all full up at my community college
teacher jokes I hold doctorates in
chemistry mathematics and engineering as
well as bas and psychology and sociology
we find out shortly that Reid is 27 and
to get the masters and doctorate and all
three of those courses would be six
years apiece minimum let's just be
generous and say it took him 12 years to
accumulate all three of these doctorates
and the 2bas he spin the BAU for at
least going on four years if the series
is moving along at a year a season ratio
and I'm thinking he was with them at
least a year or two before the series
properly starts so this puts him
graduating high school somewhere between
the ages of 8 and 10th but his wiki
fandom page says he graduated from high
school at 12 so I say all this to point
out that we can phantom pages are built
and extremely sinful also damn this
shows brave in this back to back shot of
the same students in the same seats we
see Colonel Costanza and then he's
simply gone but who cares right we're
not here for continuity we just want to
see our heroes outsmart a psychotic
murderer this information to the team
and if they're interested I'll call you
if your team is interested I would give
her every cent back at Paul Michael
Glaser would introduce himself as
detective Dave Starsky you really need
to be careful how you phrase things
mansplaining an existentialist would
never change the bulb he would allow the
darkness to Isis and a good television
show would leave dialog like this on the
cutting room floor but here we are also
remember when work sweeps were a big
deal and all your favorite shows at
stunt castings and remember how it
almost always sucked I don't understand
what hurt what are these seven homicide
victims but I don't understand is why
did Rothschild wait until they were at
the University for this reveal could
have told them about his plan from
anywhere right yeah he could have even
pulled a John Doe
to walk into the BAU and screamed at
dark now is the time to save the others
though what's going on with Jason
Alexander's accent in the show if
there's worse than Halle Berry is
disappearing dialect in x-men or Keanu
Reeves diminishing drawl in the devil's
advocate and lass you can find a way to
save them we murder victim portraits
raining from the sky like propaganda at
a parade there's way too much going on
in this title screen is the show's title
Criminal Minds or is it Criminal Minds
Behavioral Analysis Unit Quantico FBI
let us consider that we are all insane
Criminal Minds narration mind aeration
nary animal because I can do this job
I'm sorry has somebody suggested that
you can't have they not to me what boss
would play the pronoun game in the
scenario instead of trying to figure out
what's bugging one of his employees
agent Hotchner that's him
Reed and I were just approached by some
guy here with photos that he claims are
seven women he killed and I'm saying
there's a top volume so all these random
college students can hear me because TV
show
I don't think so hutch I get a hit off
of something hinky I'm bringing a man
this would fall over things you probably
shouldn't share in front of a suspect
you're about to attempt to extract
information out of are we really
supposed to believe these are the cream
of the crop and Behavioral Analysis what
is this do not forget a word he says the
rest of the time we have I also learned
from my wiki fandom research that Reid
has an eidetic memory which means he
never forgets anything in fact he can't
forget anything so cuz we're all see
even concerned about here they're trying
to piss me off it's not gonna work he's
not kidding
dude acts on the same level no matter
what the scenario not sure if that's a
good thing or a bad thing but they
should have used in acting tooling
classes called the Montaigne method why
turn yourself in imagine what the world
would have missed if da Vinci never shot
his work or imagine if Jason had said no
to this wig and this were all imagine of
all the electronics stopped working and
I couldn't finish this show am I doing
this right oh did you need something
know this force female bonding moment
was it but you know if our riding team
isn't satisfied yet we can talk about
our periods syncing up and dialogue
about pay disparity the audience loves
that of course the newscaster is
spouting off info tangentially related
to the case they're working on because
what would a crime procedural be without
convenient news position do you
understand your rights perfectly I can
have a lawyer no thank you
some games are just intended to be
played by higher intellects Jesus in
Christ this discount Hannibal Lecter
Moriarty Murdock both dis so lame what
were they going for here making a big
bad out of the asshat stock guy from
Pretty Woman harming a person weaker
than you doesn't take any special
ability neither does slamming your fist
down on the table but we all must do
what we must do professor Rothschild
would be intellectually superior TV
since I never have any normal fans
I feel URI in this disturbing scene we
see the camera taking video from inside
the torture chamber
who's taking that footage the only
camera we've been shown is attached to
the door and only able to take still
images you need a place with a lot of
privacy to hide five victims house his
locals the conclusions that are drawn
based on space is ridiculous I can think
of several places to hide a woman and
four kids a large fan a walk-in closet a
storage shed a rented hotel room maybe
in an abandoned warehouse and let's not
forget the obvious go yourself for
making me think like this TV show wait
for the presentation you know it was
more like two and a half hours after the
abduction he got there around noon which
obviously Reed could remember Rothschild
walking in late but how would he know
the exact time if he wasn't looking at a
watch or a clock and we have no evidence
he was doing either see be underlined
see B not underlined am I sitting
continuity no I'm sitting there goddamn
clear bored that nobody can read from
across the room because of the massive
television on the wall behind them using
a regular dry erase board like real
people if he hasn't been fingerprinted
he hasn't been arrested which also means
he hasn't had a passport driver's
license or been in the military there
are only four states that require
fingerprints to receive a driver's
license and Virginia isn't one of them
you don't always need a rule three man
the list of unsub traits grows but
Rossi's handwriting is so illegible
what's this folklore even if he was
using a normal whiteboard nobody would
know what was happening
fun fact in this episode golden rat net
is live-streaming victims of a serial
killer being tortured these days golden
rat net will redirect you to a website
designed to woo you into a relationship
with an entity that will never leave
your conscious for the rest of your life
let me know if you dared to visit the
site I didn't spend the last five years
of my life working on a masterpiece just
to fold to a bad Bluff especially for
someone who doesn't even have a hand to
play poker metaphors also how did Rossi
know Rothschild would take the route of
choosing to leave what if he decided to
stay and under some more pretentious
bull would Prentiss just walk in and
would that play out the same way they
were wanting it to so far I've got 39
missing brunettes in central Virginia ok
30 years old like Kaylie a narcissist
tend to be extremely preferential 28 ah
yes how would these TV show
investigation departments get anything
accomplished if it wasn't for these
magical computer program cliches Teddy's
been working on this for five years
over the last five years 17 whisker CR
seriously not given the time parameters
to work with that would seem like
seriously important information I was
thinking maybe we should give reassure
you think he's smarter than me who gives
a if he is there are lives online and
Reid is the smartest person on the team
the idea that he wouldn't be in every
interrogation or at the very least
observing from a distance is ridiculous
Jordan you are a member of this team
there is no they between great escapes
you know I was born with an extra Y
chromosome so it means I was born to be
a killer actually it usually means you
would be taller than average height of 6
foot 3 to be exact Jason Alexander is
five five so what's that about I have an
extra why it makes me a killer
that's junk science a joke you know a
lot of people say the same about
criminal profiling overall but we've
still got three hundred thirteen
episodes of this show and Counting to
contend with these kids us issues all
right all four of them it's just an odd
pattern for Kissimmee poison really you
learn that at FBI school there was a
class on the toy patterns children leave
he knows math already things galaxies
flowers and also how is this not the go
to calculating gift also also we
interrupt this criminal mind show to
bring you a very special American
version of Sherlock it's still something
this just one thing just one thing this
whole team is going up reeds Fibonacci
sequence theory which might be fine but
they're also basing this on the idea
that they have correctly identified the
seven previous victims which other than
being located close to each other and
being brunette and have zero else in
common
everything about this resolution is
bugging the Academy you kill them
because they were beautiful
you mean hypothetically well I'm just
trying to understand this math thing oh
hang in there because the reasons for
these murders started in genetics leaked
into art and math and will soon spiral
into beauty books and finally land on
vengeance don't ask questions
we're on a dramatic journey into madness
golden ratio is a subconscious
identifier of perfect luminous crazy bad
guys pounced off a lot of blah blah blah
because it sounds cooler to a writer
than it actually is cliche this is all
about my books so yeah that's where the
real problem is everyone movies TV shows
and video games don't make people kill
people
it's boring ass books written by
criminal profilers those are the real
culprits it was never about that perfect
woman are those wonderful children it
was about your team
this entire charade depended on five
people racing into the torture house
what if someone was sick that day also
let's say two people race into the front
door and are immediately killed by
assets the others we wouldn't be lemming
they're way over the sizzling corpses of
their friends laid back to hook up but
they holy I almost took an acid shower
and then probably read no I knew if I
kept prodding you that you would rise to
my challenge except you needed read to
make that happen so really Rossi played
zero part in the resolution other than
he's an author I can't twelve did you
get all that every word boss but how is
Ross's shoulder miked up the confession
was at a whisper directly into Rossi's
ear quite sexy actually very distracting
teaching yeah I teach show interrogation
at the FBI Academy and do your classes
cover the importance of being aware of
where a suspect is in relation to your
body there's gonna completely ignore
that the killer is standing over you
while you're on the phone I don't think
you're a very good teacher
you'll only face murder charges on the
original seven women yep those [ __ ]
it's all we really care about are the
people that made it into this episode
I'm gonna be
when they strap you down for that lethal
injection I'm gonna lean in real close
and tell you to say hello to your
scumbag brothers well now you've ruined
the element of surprise oh how kind of
the police that drape his jacket over
his shoulders
I'm sure this courtesy is extended to
every criminal who wears a suit coat to
an interrogation
how happy would it make you to hurt me
with impunity that hurts my feelings I
would never you wouldn't only because
there's consequences
[Music]
try Prentiss arene it's a trap hello
Neil who are you I am the architect I
created the matrix I've been waiting for
you